with DreamWorks trolls movie out on
blu-ray and DVD now it's time to take a
look at some intriguing deleted scenes
that were cut from the final version of
the movie
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm going to review
and explain the scenes from trolls that
we didn't see in the movie quick warning
there are spoilers here if you haven't
seen the movie already so if you want to
avoid those tap or click here to watch
my spoiler free review of the movie King
Pepe was initially going to hand over
his crown to Princess poppy much earlier
in the movie and we get an indication of
this in a deleted scene from the
beginning of the film which takes place
after the trolls who escaped from Bergen
town and poppy has grown up in the scene
King Pepe is listening to poppy tell the
young trolls the story of the trolls and
the bergens and when she finishes he
asks her what happened to the brave king
Pepe in this scene we see that Pepe has
become rather absent-minded and confused
as he's grown older however in the final
movie they dialed back that aspect of
the character and because his memory
wasn't so good in this deleted version
he planned to pass on his crown to
Princess poppy so she could become the
new leader of the trolls also as Poppy's
coronation was originally going to be a
much bigger event in the movie she was
going to need a special coronation dress
in fact the dress was the focus of a
cutscene that would have given more
screen time to the fashion twin satin
and chenille and also shown us closer up
how they were joined viral loop in their
hair the scene kicks off with poppy
checking in on the fashion twins to see
if her coronation dress is ready as well
as giving us a look at the coronation
dress the deleted sequence also flashes
through in a fun way a series of extra
dresses that satin and chenille have
designed for Poppy's big day including a
post rehearsal gown and after coronation
party dress and an after-after-party
muumuu dress the scene ends with poppy
shouting I want to wear them all the
scene was cut as although it's very
entertaining the filmmakers felt it was
too long and during test screenings at
DreamWorks some people thought it made
poppy seem spoiled and obnoxious by the
way if you've seen my video on the
deleted characters and rejected concepts
in trolls you'll know that in one of the
movies trailers when the villainous chef
raids the troll village poppy is dressed
in what looks like a ceremonial gown
however in the final film the same scene
shows poppy wearing her normal clothes
that's because the party
puppy was having at that point in the
film was originally going to be her
coronation party rather than just a
celebration party which it was in the
final film there was a deleted song
called bringing back happy that I was
really disappointed didn't make it into
the final movie it was going to be a
villain song for the Bergen chef where
we'd see her get deliciously bad as she
sings about how she's bringing back
happiness by cooking up the trolls that
she's captured it's a fantastic musical
number sung by Christine Baranski who
voiced chef in the movie and we get to
see some of her villainous plans to
mince up the trolls whip them into a
batter and chop them into sushi there's
a touch of Hollywood's golden age of
musicals including Carmen Miranda Esther
Williams and choreographer Busby
Berkeley to the song and dance routine
and I just love it it's such a shame it
didn't make it into the final movie as
villains songs in animations can be so
memorable for example I love Ursula's
poor unfortunate souls and the Little
Mermaid and more recently Tama Toa
SHINee in Moana however the filmmakers
didn't include the song because they
thought it made the Bergen villain too
appealing and not frightening enough now
what do you think about the deleted
scenes and song and would you like to
seen them in the movie and what's your
favorite song by a movie villain also
would you like to see a troll sequel and
what do you think should happen in it
I'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
do please like share and comment and you
can check out more of my trolls and
animation videos by tapping or clicking
here thanks for watching and see you
next time yippee-ki-yay movie lovers